so on this channel I've talked about
everything from Eco location to balance
to training your toe muscles but
sometimes I forget to cover the basics
and you don't get much more basic than
weight loss and body composition in this
video we're going to talk a little bit
about some strategies you can use to
lose weight get a bit leaner whilst
maintaining or even building muscle
so if you're looking to start losing
weight then many people will tell you to
begin with an AMR and BMR calculation
BMR stands for basal metabolic rate this
is how many calories you burn at rest
for things like blinking breathing
moving your body things that you do when
you're not exercising so you're always
burning calories then on top of this you
have your AMR active metabolic rate and
this tells you how many extra calories
you burn as a result of moving
throughout the day so this should give
you a rough average of how many calories
you burn on a daily basis and that then
can serve as the basis for your Target
whether you want to create a deficit and
lose weight whether you want to eat in
Surplus and gain weight in other words
if you eat more than you burn in terms
of calories then you'll gain weight if
you eat less than you burn in terms of
calories then you'll lose weight so a
BMR calculation looks like this there's
actually a few different calculations
like this but that doesn't really matter
you can find those online easy enough
it's also what a lot of fitness trackers
will use behind the scenes if you are
one of those to try and track your
calories in and out in theory this is
perfect but in practice not so much and
there's a few reasons for this the first
of these reasons is that this
calculation and others like it are
pretty much as useful as your BMI way
off so if we look for example we have
9.563 times weight in kilograms while
weighting kilograms is not nuanced
enough to calculate your metabolic rate
because you could be overweight and
obese in which case you likely have a
very slow metabolism or you might be
packed with muscle and muscle is highly
metabolically active meaning that you're
going to burn a lot more calories if
you're that weight and strong versus if
you're that weight and out of shape and
this just isn't taken into account by
this calculation so if you're sticking
to this religiously and you're not
losing weight it might be because you're
actually still eating too much because
you haven't taken into account the
difference between muscle and fat and
the reverse is also true likewise
hormones play a massive role and they're
not even you know referenced in these
sorts of equations many people will try
and play this down I'll say that if
you're doing your calculation and you're
eating in a calorie deficit then you
will lose weight and anyone who says
otherwise is just lying because they're
lazy well unfortunately that's just
plainly not true and the people who say
this are just fortunate enough to have
never encountered in their own lives or
if they're someone that they're training
what could happen when you have a slower
metabolic rate say for example if you
started taking steroids your
testosterone would go through the roof
you would burn many more calories build
much more muscle and your body
composition would change entirely again
not represented by this chart to a
lesser degree the same thing might be
true if you have hyper or hypothyroidism
likewise medication can change this I
know someone who started taking epilepsy
medication and they instantly lost loads
and loads of weight likewise I know
somebody started taking their
contraceptive pill and they instantly
gained loads of weight again not
represented here and the point is that
you might not be doing any of those
things but we're all so different and
our hormones are so different that this
really doesn't tell you enough what I'm
actually saying is that whilst this can
be a useful starting point because for
many people it will be fairly accurate
and it's a good guesstimate you
shouldn't just view this as the be all
and end-all and if you aren't getting
results it doesn't mean that there's
something wrong with what you're doing
it might well be that the calculation
doesn't really apply to you right now it
also means that it does make sense to
focus a little bit on changing your
hormones and your metabolic rate as well
and there are some relatively easy ways
we can do this a great example is to
build muscle like I said muscle is more
metabolically active than is fat we can
also look at changing our activity
levels throughout the day because it's
not just about what you do in the gym or
even just what you do at work it's about
what you're doing throughout the day and
how much you're moving whether you need
to walk a long way to get the train in
the morning whether you walk a dog
regularly or whether you basically just
get out of bed get into the car go to
work and then crash on the couch and get
home basically sitting all day is any
wonder that not only are you not burning
calories throughout the day but also
your metabolism is really ramped down
because it has no reason to ramp up so
what you want to do is make sure you
inject just a little bit of cardio you
don't have to go crazy with this don't
have to do long runs or really massive
workouts as long as you're doing
something on a daily basis frequently
it's going to make a big difference and
you can look at your lifestyle and make
little changes like that but an easy
solution is just to do a small small 10
minute 15 minute workout focused on
cardio and calorie burning every day and
this can be something fun everybody can
do a little bit of skipping in the
evening everyone can do a little bit of
Shadow Boxing or perhaps a little bit of
oculus Quest you can do a little bit of
beat saber which is tons of fun most
people have time to do something like
this every day and whilst you won't burn
tons of calories it adds up and it's
more about that cumulative effect than
it is about the acute number of calories
you burn in any given moment furthermore
if you can do this multiple times a day
so that you're doing a small workout
maybe a bit beat saber in the morning
and then maybe a bit of skipping before
your shower in the evening then this is
going to have an even better effect
because not only are you burning more
calories obviously twice as many but
you're also spreading them out so that
you're spiking your metabolism twice
during the day and we get the afterburn
effect or the epoch the post-exercise
oxygen consumption in other words your
heart rate is up you're consuming more
oxygen this burns more calories even
after the workout if you work out once
you get this once you work out twice you
get twice so your average heart rate
your average metabolism throughout the
day is now higher make lifestyle tweaks
and do two 10-minute sessions of some
kind of fun card you're actually going
to stick to and this is going to make a
huge difference to your body composition
if you're looking for a form of cardio
that's firm and convenient that you can
do multiple times a day potentially then
there are a few better options than
skipping skipping's great because as
long as you've got a small space
Outdoors you can do this pretty much
anywhere and it's a fantastic option
because it's actually fun in fact it's
quite addictive when you skip you get
that kind of like one more go attempt
every time you fluff up and especially
if you try and learn tricks and things
it's just far more cognitively engaging
this really increases your likelihood
actually wanting to stick with it and do
it I highly recommend today's sponsor
crossrape cross rope is a manufacturer
of jump ropes and they make really
really high quality ropes they've just
upgraded to their 2023 set which now
comes with a faster latching system new
spin mechanics a new cool design and
honestly it makes a huge difference to
the experience of skipping I've actually
been trying for ages to find a good jump
rope I ordered a bunch of them on Amazon
and other sites just picking cheap
things or things I thought sounded good
and each of them had some kind of
problem either they were too long they
were fiddle to resign some of them got
tangled up whenever you allowed any
slack and then would still be kind of
wonky when you try to jump over them you
need a good skipping over to really get
the most out of this it's just night and
day it's so much more fun because it
spins so much more easily the Rope stays
nice and straight and the slight added
weight on some of these models actually
makes it much easier if you're a
beginner like I am to learn some of the
cool tricks because it slightly slows
down the movement and that's the other
cool thing about cross rapers they make
weighted jump ropes you can get a range
of different weights ranging from really
really lighting I'm hardly going to
notice it to actually quite heavy so you
do start to notice your shoulders
working more it's tiring this is yeah
well it's a good workout it's heavy yeah
can you feel the difference yeah and
there's a 60-day trial period so there's
really no risk in giving these a go and
seeing the difference for yourself and
if you don't like them you can just send
them back and get your money back no
questions asked if you're interested in
trying them out then there's a link in
description down below and if you also
use the promo code bioneer then you also
get 15 off of your order so give it a
try and maybe this is the perfect form
of cardio to slip into your routine so
this sandwich is 417 calories which is
fair amount actually but if I was to
then burn 470 calories per exercise then
in theory I've canceled it out and it
doesn't matter so if you track your
calories in and if you perfectly knew
your AMR and your BMR which you won't
which we've spoken about
but if you did then you wouldn't add any
weight and if you burned more than you
ate then you'd lose weight and you'd
lean down the problem is as well for a
lot of people is this is pretty boring
now some people they get off on tracking
their calories perverts but I personally
find it really boring and you've got to
remember that if this is going to work
you need to do it forever like forever
to maintain that body shape and this to
me is just untenable so for a lot of
people you need to make this as easy as
possible there's a few things you can do
to do this one is just to consider that
for most people you're going to be in a
kind of equilibrium most people aren't
massively gaining weight or losing
weight they're just at a set weight
meaning that you're eating roughly your
maintenance calories if this is true
then you can just cut out a bunch of
calories and in Theory start losing
weight obviously there's metabolism
things to take into consideration you
don't want to go too drastic but if you
just cut back a little bit take some
things out of your diet you should see a
Effect one we can do this obviously is
with intermittent fasting if you just
cut out breakfast for instance you're
going to lose about 300 to 400 calories
that might be a bit much if anything
that's a very easy way to reduce your
caloric intake another option something
I really like to do is just to make my
breakfast and my lunch extremely simple
and by keeping them really simple this
way I'm able to eat what I like a bit
more eat a bit more freely in the
evening I'll repeat the same few meals
for breakfast and lunch this way I know
how many calories it is this way there's
no guesswork and it means I can eat
better when I'm having my more social
meals it's basically what I called in a
previous video eating without being a
knob about it another issue with
focusing too much on calories is it
means you can completely ignore
nutrition and nutrition is actually
really important when it comes to
maintaining good health but also losing
weight because we know that minerals and
vitamins and things will help us to
maintain healthy hormone levels that
contribute to weight loss there's this
whole movement which is the if it fits
in your Macros iif ym and the whole
notion here is that you can lose weight
eating any donuts of course because if
you only one donut a day you're gonna
lose weight but of course that's not
really a very healthy way to go about
things and it's actually going to lead
to very poor health over time I'm not
someone who's super strict with my
nutrition either but it is really
important to get healthy nutrients and
to minimize the processed foods that you
know aren't providing it with anything
that good
so just to recap if you want to start
losing weight then I highly recommend
that you take up weight training because
that muscle will be metabolically active
if possible on top of this ideally
perform at least one 10-minute session
of simple cardio every day and better
yet up this to two it's better to do two
10-minute sessions of cardio than it is
to do one 20 minute session of cardio
look for ways to be more active
throughout your day counting calories
can be very effective for some people
but I highly recommend it instead you
find ways to make what you eat more
consistent then subtract something that
you eat regularly so that you can reduce
your caloric intake see how that goes
for a bit and then if that doesn't work
then subtract something else until you
find a point where you're eating less
than your equilibrium and you start
losing a little bit of weight and make
sure you're still eating a balanced and
nutritious diet and that's pretty much a
almost foolproof way to start losing
weight
so thanks Tom for watching guys hope you
found this video useful and interesting
let me know comments down below how you
stay lean what your diet looks like and
whether you work out with that as a goal
and a big shout out to Grant Stevens for
not only filming like this video but
also demonstrating the jump rope and his
Shadow Boxing I've actually been a bit
injured lately as you guys might know
from my last video so I wasn't able to
do a lot of action stuff myself it's
awesome that Grant is just incredibly
talented in both respects and if you
want to check out his channel and I'll
put a link to the description down below
perfect if you want to learn about
martial arts if you're interested in
training that is sporadic and split
throughout your day as a way to lose
more weight but also to improve your
strength mobility and much more then
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 I'll put a
link to that in description down below
it comes with over two hours of
instructional footage and an 80 plus
page e-book either way thank you so much
for watching guys I'll see you next time
bye for now